le liban continue sa descente aux enfers
les prix des denrées alimentaires et des
produits de première nécessité ont été
multipliées par cinq depuis 2019
les femmes sont notamment touchés par la
précarité menstruel il se dit elle ne
peut plus acheter des serviettes
hygiéniques à ses filles alors c'est le
système d je prends des couches pour les
lyonnais à défaut je la mets comme ça et
je dis à ma fille d'utiliser ainsi
imaginé j'ai trois filles et les trois
ont leurs règles en même temps comment
je peux me procurer des salles et
hygiénique
surtout dans une telle situation début
juin un rapport de la banque mondiale a
classé la crise économique et financière
du liban parmi les trois épisodes de
crises les plus graves du monde depuis
le milieu du 19e siècle
le pays est sans gouvernement depuis 10
mois ou plus de 60% de la population est
passée sous le seuil de pauvreté selon
l'onu le chômage a atteint un chiffre
record 39% de la population
la monnaie du pays n'a pas été épargné
elle a perdu plus de 90% de sa valeur
face au dollar aujourd'hui que peut
espérer un pays sans gouvernement
difficile à dire la crise économique et
social a été aggravée par la pandémie de
coronavirus et l' explosion dévastatrice
au port de beyrouth en août dernier le
fonds monétaire international a proposé
son aide
mais la classe politique du pays a été
incapable d'instaurer des réformes pour
sortir le pays du chaos
depuis le pays divague
seule la paupérisation a doublé passant
de 28% de la population en 2018 à 55 %
en 2020 et les enfants subissent cette
crise de plein fouet
selon le rapport de l'unicef plus de 30%
d'enfants se couchent avec le ventre
vide
certains enfants sont contraints
d'abandonner l'école c'est le cas de
quatre cent mille d'entre eux et un
enfant sur dix a été envoyée travailler
77% des ménages n'ont pas d'argent pour
s'acheter de la nourriture leur santé et
leur sécurité sont à risques et leur
avenir est mis en jeu
de plus en plus de familles sont
obligées de recourir à des mesures
d'adaptation négative
notamment en sautant des repas en
envoyant leurs enfants travailler dans
des conditions souvent dangereuses ou en
mariant leur jeune fille et cette
paupérisation concerne également la
classe moyenne qui jusqu'à présent
vivait décemment après un petit sursaut
inattendu
le parlement libanais a approuvé une
carte d'approvisionnement entre 90 et
130 $ qui sera accordé aux ménages les
plus pauvres
500000 fanni devrait en bénéficier mais
les libanais n'attendent plus rien de
leur classe dirigeante en 2020 après la
catastrophe du port ce qui a été appelé
l'initiative française est aujourd'hui
un flop en août 2020 emmanuel macron
était alors apparu tel un sauveur
paradant dans les rudes un beyrouth
ravagé promettant d'aider le pays à se
libérer des griffes d'une classe
politique corrompue mais le constat est
amer
après quelques visites seulement des
sanctions sont tombées à l'égard des
figures politiques
rien d'exceptionnel selon un
éditorialiste du journal américain font
une panda si le président français n'a
pas tenu ses engagements
le problème principal était que la
réussite du plan français reposait sur
cette même classe politique qui avait
été dès le départ jugé responsable des
catastrophes à l'oeuvre dans le pays
son refus d'engager des réformes est
sans doute la principale raison de
l'échec du plan français l'impasse
libanaise est en partie la faute de
macron la réticence de la france à
sanctionner sévèrement les élites
politiques en place pour se contenter de
les supplier de prendre des mesures et
est d'une naïveté confondante et a fini
par avoir des conséquences délétères
une étude publiée par informations
internationales estiment que la crise
économique à laquelle le liban est
confronté ferait grimper le taux de
chômage est 65 % de la population active
avant le 17 octobre début du soulèvement
populaire on comptait 25 % de chômeurs
dans le pays
selon l'étude si aucune mesure d'urgence
n'est prise le liban pourrait compter un
million de chômeurs pour la première
fois de son histoire alors qu'il compte
six millions d'habitants